do you write long hand still or
absolutely you do why can't write poetry
on the computer mate wow I wrote
Reservoir Dogs long hand and I had to
type it up I write it like that and then
I don't type but I then I type it up
afterwards and I didn't even have a
typewriter I borrowed my girlfriend at
the time her little Smith Corona
typewriter and I just typed it up yeah I
don't do this I I'm not this off I'm I'm
like this yeah one finger at a time and
that's kind of and that's how I did PP
fiction and in glorious bastards but you
know literally the whole process of me
writing by hand
when I now have to type it up by one
finger and just literally I don't I
don't trust it to hold anything from
memory so I print up every page as I
finish that's an important part of the
process to me that's like the you know
that's the final draft coming out you
tend to overwrite when you're writing by
hand because it's just cost you nothing
to just blah blah blah blah blah with
the pen but when you got to type it up
with one finger it's better if the [__]
ain't [__] Shakespeare it's got
to
go